If you don't like cans over your ears and you don't like earbuds that,
like, go into your ear like that,
this is the solution you've been waiting for.
It kinda hooks onto your ear,
and then it has a little speaker
that kind of sits just on top of your ear, so.
And they really.
They're not going anywhere.
They stick on your ear. They don't go anywhere.
So. I didn't even know this was a fucking option.
This is where you charge it.
I linked right here in the TikTok shop.
These make an amazing Christmas gift for, like, teenagers or anybody.
They make an amazing little holiday gift for anybody,
you know, who wants something like this.
So the link right here if you want some.